five years ago when Google announced
Chromebooks laptops that couldn't do
anything without an internet connection
it sounded like a joke and what's the
deal with these laptops that only browse
the web when you're gonna sell us next
Google and oven that only roast chicken
the Chromebooks are no laughing matter
anymore
while they might have started out as
simple secondary computers they've been
slowly gaining features that bring them
closer to you know real laptops they
even look like them to Samsung's new
$400 model has a roomy thirteen inch HD
screen and a really high-end looking
design and HP has one for $300 with a 14
inch screen and Intel's latest
processors but can any of these sub $400
Chromebooks do the job of a Mac or
Windows PC after living with them for a
week I can safely say they're no longer
a joke there's still some things I'd
rather do on a real laptop no I'm not
watching Netflix at work but Chromebooks
have been good at just that watching
Netflix stalking people on Facebook but
how do they perform when it actually
comes to doing work finding web app
alternatives to Windows and Mac
productivity programs is actually easier
than you think in addition to Google
Docs there's Microsoft Word online and
many companies offer a web version of
outlook for your email and calendar
there's also a good desktop photo editor
called Pixlr managing all those apps is
better now to that you can put windows
side-by-side and launch apps from the
toolbar you can even view all your apps
by swiping up on the trackpad those
multitasking features are useful though
there's room for improvement including
some better file management tools but
there's still some big cance when it
comes to working on a Chromebook even
though there are web-based VPN tools for
accessing your office network remotely
my company doesn't offer a compatible
one and even though I do like to live in
the cloud I still like to print on paper
you can't just plug in a printer
Google's cloud print only works with
select printers and setting it up is a
hassle I'm still waiting for my stuff to
print most other peripherals played
really nicely with a Chromebook
my external monitor my external hard
drive and my wireless mouse just worked
it was easy to load photos up on the
computer
though there's only 16 gigabytes of
space on most of these so you'll want to
ship those files to the cloud good thing
Chromebooks come with 100 gigabytes of
free Google Drive space but my biggest
issue with these Chromebooks has been
what happens if there's no internet
Google's fixed a lot of that now but
it's not perfect
you can prepare Google Drive in Google
Docs for offline use but they don't
always load when you lose that
connection that said some other third
party apps like quick note worked really
well offline what do you call a laptop
that only runs Google's Chrome OS
actually a decent Mac or PC alternative
top crowd tonight oh crap
ok sure Chromebooks still can't do all
the things a traditional laptop can and
I still prefer my MacBook Air for
multitasking and file organization the
Chromebooks can now do far more than
just surf the web yet they also maintain
the original benefits like good battery
life and a simple interface if that
sounds good to you I'd go for this 279
dollar Dell Chromebook 11 if you want
something with a higher resolution
screen I'd go for the $400 Chromebook 2
from Samsung depending on what you're up
to you may never miss the real thing